do you guys think
because i don't know
i feel like naturally like people used
to get married
so young
and now like the dating game is so
different
i agree with you but this happened
because
of social media oh yeah
and people are more accessible now so
before game used to go to high school
all you knew was the people in your high
school then you went to college and you
met a lot more people
then all you knew was the people in your
college and your high school
and if you wanted to
date anybody it would be those people
now social medias come here
you can be somebody in taiwan
meet somebody in australia
they may tickle your fancy
tickle your face that's a good one
i need a bed to stay here
i would like to chime in on that real
quick
so
i like to pick people's brain
i after i think when i first came back
from my injury with the calf injury
um i met that i was talking to a couple
i took i was took this old a couple
irish couple
married
married 57 years together for 60.
and they would give me basically this is
a positive vibe and i'm saying
why are you still with him i asked the
woman i like to pick a woman's brain
first ask that woman why is she with him
she was giving me the whole spell i'm
gonna try to sum it up but basically she
was telling me you guys i feel sorry for
she was saying specifically she feel
sorry for the women in this day and age
right because
men especially men of a higher status
have more options that being said
um she's not saying certain women don't
have our options because we had talked
about that as well
but it was one of those things where
basically
she was saying people don't work through
things
anymore apart you guys have a
disagreement people break up and like oj
said they can quickly find somebody on
social media well do you want do you
want to know an interesting stat
if you ask
me
80 of women what they want in a guy they
list 20 of men so the reason that women
hate men is because we're all sleeping
with the same ones i agree yeah
some would argue it's an even smaller
percentage than that
like for for example how tall are you
guys you're what you're what i am a star
boy but yeah okay stop stop we're not
gonna argue with the comments like
respectfully
i've said this so many times
no no i've said this
okay okay
okay okay well this is this is my
podcast and we're not gonna do that here
okay um
but um
i forgot what i was even talking about
oh okay okay so six five and six so the
reason like i'm tall right
so i'm i'm six foot right so if i want
to date a guy that's taller than me
that's six foot and up right that's only
15 percent of guys oh [ __ ] and so yeah
and so if you go taller than that it's
like yeah yeah we're really treasured
then
this is why this is what this is where
the basketball teams run through school
yeah like do you think that's what
you've seen like it's a small percentage
of guys that get all the girls is that
what you've seen definitely definitely
yeah yeah
and do you feel like women think that
they're hotter than they are typically
women search for power money and status
boom that's true
a check mark look at simon levine has a
girlfriend that's a model
the tinder so he still has a girl
because he's famous i saw something on
snapchat yeah
no was it snapchat it was tick tock he's
on tick tock so i mean tick tock it was
it was something it was some social
media yeah it was one uh
when girls somebody said to a girl
put the
the male version of yourself on like a
field or something
if you don't like yourself you need to
lower your standards
oh the titan tic tac
yeah and a lot of people were angry in
the comments like ah well it's because
well it's because that small percentage
of guys will still sleep with like the
guy that's a nine or a 10 will still
sleep with a girl that's a fourth
why there's a reason behind it i think
we evaluate as much there's that no is
this it there's a bigger reason why it's
a biological reason you guys are
programmed to spread your seed where
women we have more of a costume
you literally are like biologically yes
you are yes you are men have a higher
sex drive than women i agree
[Music]
the testosterone that we have is higher
than women that being said we also
spread naturally
if a woman what wanted to have a child
she could only have one child the year
yeah exactly yeah yeah i could literally
go around the world if there were no
stds
asterisks about that
we can say listen we can have literally
like 500 kids in the world yeah oh god i
am not spreading anything
i'm not saying all men choose to do that
i'm saying like like everyone we have
nature right go
ahead she's right
if you listen like if you listen to what
she's saying she's not saying you as
individuals i know i agree she's saying
men as a collective
the og listen listen listen
i could go out and throw around
and
impregnate as many women as i want to
the vet
the vets oj the vet is speaking
women could get pregnant one time and
they'd done out the game for nine months
game
so based on biology she's right
then it comes down to individual
churches
i love it some people aren't just out
here slinging
why do
[Music]
well in the same way like women we're
programmed to get the highest like
status guy that we can so we're trying
to
work
yeah like it depends each girl has a
different like thing like for a super
religious girl like it might be the guy
that's high up in the church right for a
girl that cares about instagram felt
like whatever status she cares about
but you know it doesn't mean that every
single girl is going to leave her
husband the second you know someone
better than him is interested in elba
chris brown
the usual
yeah it's just like our general nature
is you know i agree
but social media i don't think social
media has changed the game as much
as birth control has because when you
added birth control to the game that
took away the consequence like before
women could just sleep with whoever but
like you run a really big risk of
getting pregnant but you bring in birth
control that takes the consequence of a
child and so if you take away the
consequences like they're gonna do it
more
if you take away the consequences
people will do the actions
like i i bet you
if people wouldn't go to jail for murder
yeah more people would do that
no no that's okay
i'm saying what like i could like your
whole head the whole movie the movie
yeah we like to
is based on that yeah they take away the
consequences for 24 hours and people out
here doing crazy stuff yeah
doing them doing a madness yeah but um
where were we well we were talking about
i was saying how birth control changed
the game yes birth control did change
the game
it made people it made the consequences
less well and i think it kind of
inflated girls egos too because now they
have access to
like these guys that they wouldn't sleep
with before and then social media on top
of that yeah everybody else accessible
yeah so what like tinder what's that
what's another one
hinge
what's another one instagram yeah
instagram facebook twitter all of them
all of them things there google yeah
google yeah you could google anybody's
name and find them well and like